there's been a lot of hype about new
networks and perhaps some of that hype
is justified given how well they're
working but it turns out that so far
almost all the economic value created by
new networks has been through one type
of machine learning called supervised
learning let's see what that means and
let's go to some examples in supervised
learning you have some input X and you
want to learn a function mapping it to
some output Y so for example just now we
saw the holding price prediction
application where you input some
features of a home and try to output or
estimate the price Y here are some other
examples that neural networks have been
applied to very effectively possibly the
single most lucrative application of
deep learning today is online
advertising of maybe not the most
inspiring but certainly very lucrative
in which by inputting and add
information about an ad to the website
is thinking of showing you and some
information about the user new networks
have gotten very good at predicting
whether or not you click on an ad and by
showing you and showing users the ads
that you're most likely to click on this
has been an incredibly lucrative
application of neural networks and
multiple companies because the ability
to show you as that you're more likely
to click on as a direct impact on the
bottom line of some of the very large
online advertising companies computer
vision has also made huge strides in the
last several years mostly due to deep
learning so you might implement image
and once you output an index say from
one to a thousand trying to tell you if
on this picture it might be anyone of
say a thousand different images so you
might use that for photo tagging I think
the recent progress in speech
recognition has also been very exciting
where you can now input an audio clip to
a neural network and have it output a
text transcript machine translation has
also made huge strides thanks to deep
learning where now you can have a neural
network input an English sentence and
directly output so your Chinese sentence
and in autonomous driving you might
input an image say a picture of what's
in front of your car as well as some
information from a radar and based on
that maybe a neural network can be
trained to tell you the position of the
other cars on the road so this becomes a
key component in autonomous driving
systems so a lot of the value creation
through neural networks has been through
your cleverly selecting what should be X
and what should be Y for your particular
problem and is fitting the supervised
learning component into often a bigger
system such as an autonomous vehicle it
turns out that 20 different types of
neural networks are useful for different
applications for example in the real
estate application that we saw in the
previous video we use a gyro so be
standard neural network architecture
right maybe for real estate and online
advertising might be a relatively
standard new network like the one that
we saw for image applications will often
use convolutional neural networks often
abbreviated CNN and for sequence data so
for example audio as a temporal
component right audio is played out over
time so audio is most naturally
represented as a one dimensional time
series there's a one dimensional
temporal sequence and so for sequence
data you often use an RNN or recurrent
neural network language you know English
and Chinese the alphabets or the words
come one at a time so language is also
most naturally represented as sequence
data and so in more complex versions of
RNAs are often used for these
applications and then for more complex
applications like autonomous driving
where you have an image then I suggest
more of a CN n convolutional neural net
structure and radar info which is you
know something something quite different
you might end up with more custom or
some more complex hybrid neural network
architecture
so just a bit bit more concrete about
what are the standard CNN and RNN
architectures so in the literature you
might have seen pictures like this so
that's a standard neural net you might
have seen pictures like this but this is
an example of a convolutional neural
network and we'll see in a later course
exactly what this picture means and how
you can implement is but convolutional
networks are often used for image data
and you might also have seen pictures
like this and you learned how to
implement this in a later course
recurrent neural networks are you're
very good for this type of
one-dimensional right sequence data
there is a may be a temporal component
you might also have heard about
applications of machine learning to both
structured data and unstructured data
here's what determines mean structured
data means basically you know databases
of data so for example in housing price
prediction you might have a database
with a column that tells you the size in
the number of bedrooms so this is
structured data or you know in
predicting whether or not a user will
click on an ad you might have
information about the user such as the
age some individual the ad and then
labels Y that you're trying to predict
so that's structured data meaning that
each of the features such as size of the
house or number bedrooms or the age of a
user has a very very well-defined
meaning in contrast unstructured data
refers to things like audio raw audio or
images where you might want to recognize
what's in the image or text here the
features might be the pixel values in an
image or the individual words any piece
of text historically has been much
harder for computers to make sense of
unstructured data compared to structured
data and in fact the human race has
evolved to be very good at understanding
audio tubes as well as images and then
text was a more recent invention but
people are just really good at
interpreting unstructured data and so
one of the most exciting things
about the rise of neural networks is
that thanks to deep learning
thanks for neural networks computers are
now much better and interpreting
unstructured data as well compared to
just a few years ago and this creates
opportunities for many new exciting
applications that use speech recognition
image recognition natural language
processing on text much more than was
possible even just two or three years
ago I think because people have a
natural empathy to understanding
unstructured data you might hear about
neural network successes on unstructured
data more in the media because it's just
cool when the neural network recognizes
a cat we all like that that we all know
what that means but it turns out that a
lot of short-term economic value that
new networks are creating has also been
on structured data such as much better
advertising systems much better product
recommendations and just a much better
ability to process the giant databases
that many companies have to make
accurate predictions from them so in
this course a lot of the techniques will
go over will apply to both structured
data and to unstructured data for the
purposes of explaining the algorithms we
will draw a little bit more on examples
that use unstructured data but as you
think through applications of your
networks within your own team I hope you
find both uses for them in both
structured and unstructured data so
neural networks have transformed
supervised learning and are creating
tremendous economic value it turns out
though that the basic technical ideas
behind your networks have most even
around sometimes for many decades so why
is it then that they're only just now
taking off and working so well in the
next video we'll talk about why is only
quite recently that neural networks have
become this incredibly powerful tool
that you can use